coffee on a Tuesday in block of 27 okay
so if you're like me it wasn't or it
won't be until the last semester of
college undergrad when you really catch
the bug of learning now there must be a
thousand reasons for this belated
development reasons which are universal
and so forgivable the most conspicuous
being that high school literally rips it
out of you in favor of a more relevant
apparatus that is a system for
navigating social relationships in other
words a system for how to be cool I'm
not totally sure that it's a bad thing
this development of a social aptitude I
actually think that there is such a
thing as cool and I would define a cool
person as someone who engages others
with their ideas someone who is
receptive enough to friends and
acquaintances and even strangers to see
when the other is clearly not interested
in what you're saying telling a story
that your audience can't possibly relate
to is not cool boasting is not cool
isolation is not cool I don't go in for
winners and losers but I do go in for ku
okay so there was this one time in
eighth grade when I was acting out in
class being loud and clownish and stupid
and my teacher mr. Leventhal told me to
go wait outside you know that horrible
exile of secondary school when you get
reprimanded and everybody sees it and it
was even worse because I like this
teacher you know we were supposed to be
friends well he came out into the
hallway with a conciliatory look and
said to me Evan look I know you're funny
everyone in that class knows you're
funny but being funny doesn't mean a
damn thing if you don't have timing to
this day that is the best certainly the
most influential advice I've ever gotten
there's no question that it changed my
life not right away but good advice
never does
gradually it sunk down and took hold and
in moments when in the past I would have
blurted out some thoughtless vulgarity I
instead opted to keep silent to listen
to feel the waves of a conversation and
say something or tell a joke only when
the moment was primed for it it's a lot
like surfing and like surfing you're
going to wipe out a lot in the course of
getting better no matter how
good you get the day will never come
when you've said your last idiotic thing
word of advice don't trust anyone who
never makes a fool of him or herself
because that person is an alien the more
we grow the more this mastery of timing
augments our ability to get along in the
world it has its application in a
perfectly executed joke yes but timing
isn't everything it's in the way we
treat our family our friends our
teachers our bosses our employees a good
relationship depends on knowing when you
should for example be deferential when
you should stick up for your opinion on
understanding when it's okay to offer
help to a friend and when it's okay to
ask for it timing plays a huge part in
your writing a good story is not
interesting but for the rhythm at which
it's told the same goes for a good
speech or a good lecture or a good vlog
I do think that it's a natural part of
growing up but it's one that becomes so
obsessive in the early years that the
desire to learn for learnings sake gets
pushed to the fringe because it holds no
value in social currency and it's an
obsession that lingers into the first
years of college because we're all so
anxious to fit in and that's natural too
but I think eventually it dawns on us
that what it meant to be cool in high
school is not really gonna be enough to
make a happy life after graduating
college I became so extremely frustrated
with how little I really knew it seemed
to me that all my knowledge was like so
many free-floating clouds that had no
connection what I learned was easily
forgotten and often contradictory I had
the timing stuff down but now I wanted
to know things I wanted to know
everything so I resolved to start at the
beginning with the foundation of all
knowledge philosophy and I began to read
like I sometimes eat potato chips
ferociously and the result of all that
was this a 36 page discourse on truth
summing up everything that I thought and
believed I had it printed up at Kinkos
and I sent a copy out to all my family
and friends as if to say here this is
what I know and this is who I am if
you're interested to read it you can
find a link to an online copy in the
doobly-doo I just reread it two years
later and I don't agree with everything
that's in there but that's to be
expected there's still a lot of things
in there that I do agree with for me it
symbolizes more the beginning of the
period of my life when I became obsessed
with learning and it's an appetite that
is
perpetually unquenchable it never gets
boring because there's always something
more to learn the timing was ironically
not so great all of this happened after
I had already graduated college after
the countless thousands of dollars were
already spent on an education that I
wish I could go back and get more out of
I would have taken so many more liberal
arts classes if I had to do it again but
aha
to the point of this circuitous video
you can do it again on this phone I have
an app called iTunes U on it there are
literally dozens of courses from schools
like Stanford Yale Harvard do you know
how much Harvard costs in tuition per
year do you know how much work you have
to put in to get into that school and
they put their courses on my phone for
free I mean am I the only one who thinks
this is awesome right now I am taking a
course a Stanford course called the
international system in the 20th century
on my couch with a beer for no money at
all and I don't have to do any of the
homework
you